[Fabien] Salut ! Ça  y est, je viens enfin de rentrer de
Suisse où j'ai passé trois jours à
Lausanne et c'était vraiment top de
vous rencontrer, on s'est éclaté tant au
spectacle qu'après le spectacle. Merci beaucoup d'être venu là-bas.
Et si vous êtes intéressés aussi à venir me voir en spectacle et qu'on se rencontre après,
les prochaines dates sont le 10
décembre
à Clayes-sous-Bois dans le 78, le 31
décembre – je fais le 31 pour la dernière vidéo de l'année –
à Versailles à la Royale Factory, avec mon pote Philippe Roche, y'a deux horaires.
Aujourd'hui, je vous ai
mis un message sur Snap et sur
Facebook vous proposant de vous faire
une petite mentalisation par vidéo.
Pour ça je vous ai demandé de
m'envoyer une photo ou une vidéo de vous
avec un jeu de cartes, complet ou non,
sur Snapchat.
Et je vais prendre quelqu'un maintenant, au hasard.
Alors forcément vous
avez été nombreux à répondre donc je
vais faire circuler comme ça mon doigt,
et puis au pif on va tomber sur quelqu'un, forcément.
Rémi Degreve.
Promis, d'ici 45, je me serai coiffé.
Ah oui, d'accord. Il m'a envoyé dix mille photos, en fait.
Salut, Rémi, c'est Fabien Olicard. Alors, je suis pas plus coiffé que toi ; par contre,
je viens de te choisir au hasard
donc si tu pouvais m'envoyer…
… ton adresse Skype.
[Rémi] Essai numéro 2. Est-ce que tu me vois ?
[Fabien] Oui ! Je te vois.
Je te vois, je t'entends bien ! Alors, ça va ? T'habites où ?
[Rémi] J'habite à Leers, dans le nord, à côté de Lille.
[Fabien] Ah d'accord ! Tu sais que je viens jouer à Lille le 6 et le 7 janvier
Bam ! La promo !
[Rémi] Je vais prendre mes places, j'ai vu que tu passais au Spotlight.
[Fabien] Yes, c'est ça, ouais. Exactement.
Je suis un petit peu speed parce que c'est la vidéo qui va sortir à 17 heures.
[Rémi] Ouais… en flux tendu, comme d'hab' !
[Fabien] Ouais, exactement, voilà.
Je me suis dis : «Ah, on va faire un truc Skype». Et donc tu verras, dans la vidéo,
j'ai passé mon doigt, comme ça, sur…
Au pif, sur Snap, et je suis tombé sur toi et tes trente mille messages.
Est-ce que tu vas pouvoir caler la caméra pour avoir les mains libres ?
[Rémi] Ouais…
[Fabien] Ah, j'ai exactement le même T-shirt, «keep calm».
[Rémi] Ah, je l'ai mis pour toi. Un T-shirt avec texte !
[Fabien] Yes ! C'est un des premiers
que j'avais mis, et la première fois que j'ai sauté en parachute
j'avais celui-ci. Est-ce que tu peux mélanger les cartes ?
On va commencer par bien mélanger les cartes.
Tu m'as bien entendu, ouais ?
[Rémi] Ouais.
[Fabien] On a un petit délai, ouais.
Donc mélange bien les cartes, voilà, comme ça.
[Rémi] Je les ai mélangées avant que t'arrives.
[Fabien] Ouais mais bon, il faut qu'on prouve à tout le monde que les cartes sont bien mélangées.
[Rémi] Ça marche. Tu veux les jokers, ou pas ?
[Fabien] Peu importe.
[Rémi] OK. Bah ils sont pas dedans.
[Fabien] OK, ça roule.
[Rémi] Voilà, je pense qu'on est bien.
[Fabien] Moi, je vais préparer une petite prédiction.
Ah oui, toi tu me vois pas… bah oui.
Forcément toi tu me vois moins.
Je viens de mettre une carte à l'intérieur, regarde. Je vous fais voir.
Je viens de mettre une carte à
l'intérieur de l'enveloppe, et l'enveloppe,
faut forcément que vous puissiez la voir, et
ici, et toi aussi.
Hé ben je vais la tenir comme ça, tout le long.
(Rire) Comme ça, ce sera parfait.
[Rémi] OK, c'est bon, je la vois.
Alors voici le but du jeu. T'as le jeu dans ta main gauche, c'est ça ? Tu vas mettre ta main droite
au-dessus du jeu comme une pince.
Exactement.
Et tu vas prendre un petit paquet de cartes.
Dix, quinze, vingt cartes. Un petit paquet.
Tu le prends, tu le lèves, tu retournes le jeu.
Tu retournes les cartes et tu les reposes sur le paquet. Face en l'air.
[Rémi] Je les retourne comme ça ?
[Fabien] Exactement. Parfait.
Maintenant, tu remets ta main par au-dessus
et tu vas descendre plus profondément,
au-delà de la moitié.
Tu lèves.
Tu retournes.
Et tu reposes.
[Rémi] Ça marche.
[Fabien] Et dernière action,
tu vas passer toutes les cartes qui
sont en l'air
donc tu vois tu passes les cartes qui
sont en l'air, comme ça.
Tu les prends.
Tu les sépares, tu les prends.
Et tu les places sous le jeu, face en bas.
[Rémi] Donc dans le bon sens ?
[Fabien] Exactement, et en bas.
[Rémi] Comme ça ?
[Fabien] Ouais, exactement. Parfait.
Y'a maintenant une carte au-dessus du jeu.
Une carte complétement aléatoire.
Est-ce que tu peux la prendre et la retourner ?
Est-ce que tu peux nous la faire voir ?
[Fabien] Est-ce que tu veux…
[Rémi] C'est la dame de carreau.
[Fabien] Est-ce que la dame de carreau
te plaît, est-ce que tu veux qu'on s'arrête là, ou est ce que tu veux qu'on continue ?
[Rémi] Ouais, non, je vais la garder.
[Fabien] Tu veux qu'on s'arrête là ?
T'es sûr de toi ?
[Rémi] Ouais.
[Fabien] OK.
Je vais te faire voir
quelle carte moi j'avais mis à
l'intérieur de l'enveloppe.
T'as choisi la profondeur que tu
voulais à chaque fois.
T'allais comme tu voulais à
chaque fois.
Et moi j'ai une carte dedans. Y'a rien d'autre, hein, je vous le fais bien voir quand même.
Y'a une carte et une seule carte.
C'était la… dame de carreau, jeune homme ! Exactement.
[Rémi] Excellent !
[Fabien] Est-ce que tu veux qu'on le refasse vite fait ou pas ?
[Rémi] Ouais, on peut, on peut !
[Fabien] Alors remets le jeu toujours face en bas dans ta main.
[Rémi] Euh… Donc, toujours, je garde les cartes dans le mauvais sens et tout ? Et on continue ?
[Fabien] Ouais. En fait, elles se sont toutes remises dans le bon sens en faisant ça.
[Rémi] Ah ouais, logique.
[Fabien] La dame de carreau, elle est où ?
[Rémi] Elle est toujours au-dessus.
[Fabien] Alors prends-là et mets là dans
le milieu du jeu.
[Rémi] OK. C'est bon.
[Fabien] Alors notre ami Rémi m'a
demandé qu'on recommence. Alors voici
ma prédiction ce coup-ci.
Donc, comme tout à l'heure, tu mets la main
au-dessus du paquet.
Tu prends un petit paquet de quelques
cartes. Tu relèves. Tu retournes. Tu reposes.
[Rémi] C'est bon.
[Fabien] Tu remets la main dessus, tu vas plus profondément, où tu veux.
Tu prends, tu lèves, tu retournes.
Yes. Maintenant, tu passes toutes les cartes face en l'air et tu les mets sous le jeu face en bas.
[Rémi] Hop !
[Fabien] Avant que tu retournes la première carte, je vais te faire voir ma prédiction.
Ma prédiction c'est ça. C'est le quatre de carreau.
Est-ce que toi tu peux retourner la
première carte ?
[Rémi] C'est un quatre de carreau.
[Fabien] Oui ! Le quatre de carreau de Rémi !
Bravo mon pote !
Ça va, ça t'a plu ?
[Rémi] Bravo, bravo.
Ah ouais, ça fait bizarre, hein !
[Fabien] On voit que ça lui a plu, et tu vois en même temps un peu d'agacement.
[Rémi] Ouais. C'est… frustrant.
[Fabien] Bah oui, tu m'étonnes ! Et puis alors, ça, effectivement t'as raison…
Tu suis la chaine depuis longtemps, toi, ou pas ?
[Rémi] Ouais, depuis…
Depuis… je crois, deux vidéos avant Pierre Croce. Donc, le mois de janvier.
[Fabien] Ah oui ! Mois de janvier, grave.
Donc toi tu sais, mais tout le monde le sait pas. En fait, de temps en temps, j'invite
des gens sur la chaine
ou je fais sur Skype. Et c'est pas des choses que j'explique forcément, parce que
mon but c'est aussi de vous bluffer
de temps en temps, et voilà,
parce que ça m'amuse et c'est aussi
l'essence même de la chaîne.
Donc j'espère que je t'ai bluffé, et j'espère que ça t'a plu.
[Rémi] Ouais, ça m'a plu. Et c'est bluffant.
[Fabien] Ah, cool ! Merci beaucoup ! La vidéo elle sort à 17 heures,
hésite pas à regarder les
commentaires.
[Rémi] Ouais, bah je vais aller checker ça.
Je viendrai te voir à Lille, alors, du coup. Au Spotlight. J'espère qu'il reste des places !
Je vais aller voir ça tout de suite.
[Fabien] Ouais, il en reste. J'ai regardé ce matin, il en reste. Et puis…
Envoie-moi par Snap ou quoi, quel jour tu viens, si c'est le vendredi ou le samedi,
et on se boira un verre. Je t'offre un verre à la fin.
À bientôt, Rémi !
[Rémi] Bon montage !
[Fabien] Merci, ciao !
Et voilà, cette mentalisation par Skype est déjà terminée.
Alors, oui, c'était un
mélange de magie, de mentalisme, mais
c'était pour changer un petit peu. J'espère que ça vous aura plu. Si c'est
le cas n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir puisque
le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an du premier janvier au trente-et-un
décembre. Merci à Rémi d'avoir participé,
c'était super cool, et à tous ceux qui
avait envoyé un Snap. On se le refera de temps en temps, c'est promis.
Rendez-vous demain, à 17 heures. Ciao !
(Générique de fin)